sometimes a movie showcases in its plot
an idea that's just so good you can't
believe someone hasn't done it yet
seriously renting yourself out to be a
best man for hire for tens of thousands
of dollars I would do that I guess it's
probably more advantageous to take that
idea and make a movie about it
financially speaking so I guess that's
why no one's done The Wedding ringer so
The Wedding ringer stars Kevin Hart he
is a best man for hire for enough money
you can hire him and he will be your
best man at your wedding if you're
someone who just doesn't have enough
friends or a friend to do it Josh GAD in
this movie he is that guy he doesn't
have a friend he doesn't have someone to
be the best man he doesn't have the
seven groomsmen he needs yeah Kevin
Hartz can act to pull off a miracle in
this movie that's really what this movie
is they have to establish their
backstories and they're making [ __ ] up
and they have to pull off the biggest
wedding scam since wedding crashers and
the movie's surprisingly funny first of
all Kevin Hart the dude is just I think
he's funny he's hilarious he's really
good at the fast-talking [ __ ] yeah he
plays the same thing and everything
absolutely but I really feel like in a
world where Kevin Hart plays the same
thing and everything someone was like
okay he's perfect for this like Vince
Vaughn he's the same thing and
everything but he put him in wedding
crashers perfect and Josh GAD was good
in the movie too what I liked is that
they worked well together I actually
bought their friendship that's blooming
you know Kevin Hart's like no no it's a
business arrangement you're not renting
a friend you're renting a best man we
don't have to be friends were not gonna
be friends we're not gonna talk after
the wedding and of course you know
they're gonna develop a friendship that
you know Kevin Hartz get into nine it
absolutely happens like that but you do
buy it you do buy the fact that these
two are actually starting to grow close
and that's also one of the downsides of
this movies this movie plays out exactly
how you think it's gonna play out from
watching the trailer
admit it you saw the trailer and you
were like yeah it's gonna be a
by-the-numbers comedies gonna go down
like this this this it does no
deviations no variations it goes down
exactly like that that being said it
worked in the movie and the movie was
good in the sense that a comedies job is
to make you laugh and I laughed in this
movie I have had friends who've gotten
married I've seen many weddings nobody
likes the process leading up to a
wedding but as you're watching the
process roll out in this movie you're
like I'm having me some fun
yeah this movie is just a by-the-numbers
thing that'd be fine they'd be like okay
I'm not faulting you for it whatever be
your generic comedy as long as you make
me laugh well when it gets so cliched
that our team
misfits have to take on you know like
the football team I start going really
you're gonna play that's that is as
cliche as it gets wedding movie people
play football throw it at the screen
because it works in everything that
being said it was really funny how
intense that scene was it reminded me of
that campfire slaughter and Lost Boys
era out for blood that [ __ ] was business
honestly you're not gonna walk out of
this movie good always you that was a
completely new comedy experience for
wedding movies you're gonna see the
movie he's gonna make you laugh it's
gonna be cliche it's gonna be exactly
what you think it's gonna be but Kevin
Hart's good Josh GAD is good they worked
well together you like saying that in
the end the movies not only what you
think it's going to be but it's what you
think you want and it is what she wants
you just want to laugh so have fun
laughing cuz The Wedding ringer is a
pretty good time no alcohol required
right so what's your favorite wedding
movie I was gonna say wedding comedy but
[ __ ] if it's a drama that's it whatever
it is coming below that mean now and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]